what's going on guys this is rob and i
got my cup of coffee this morning it is
currently 8 30 a.m let's get to talking
about john krasinski's
reed richards i feel like i should be a
radio announcement good morning rob core
it's 8 30 in the morning right now we
got a nice cool 55 degree morning cup of
coffee to get us going traffic's pretty
light out there make sure you enjoy your
day and it's going to be nice and sunny
with a high of 86 degrees
you all have a good one
let's kick things off with some
california love by tupac and dr dre uh
let's talk about let's talk about john
kozinski's reid richards so here's the
thing so something that i've noticed and
i'm sure a lot of you all have noticed
it too is that leading up to doctor
strange too the rumors about it
krasinski playing reed richards it had
been a hyped up thing and and i've been
advocating this for years and while i
wouldn't go as far as to say i was the
first person to say that honestly it's
impossible to know um i would like to
believe i was one of the earliest
proponents of krasinski playing reed
richards in the marvel cinematic
universe in some capacity i was always a
fan of krazynski and emily blunt playing
reed and susan respectively and then
they can choose who in the hell else
ever to play johnny and ben grimm but
those are the two that i wanted the most
and so it's kind of funny because
looking in the aftermath of doctor
strange 2 it actually seems to be a
little divisive now i'm not buzzfeed i'm
not like the entire community is pissed
about krasinsky playing right i'm not
going to like overblow what's actually
going on but i will say that it's a
little more divisive than i thought it
would be
you know coming out of that i thought
people would just be over the moon at
the idea of krasinsky playing reed
richards and and honestly i thought he
did great i think the issues that went
on in doctor strange too
really had nothing to do with krazynski
i think that's like the least of our
concerns right and then and you know
we'll probably talk about some of those
over the course of this because there's
some things in the movie that just don't
make sense and it seems like a little
bit of lazy writing but all in all in
terms of of reid richards i thought
krasinski was awesome
do i think that the way he depicted reed
is identical to the way reed would be in
the comics
no but i moved past that years ago i
remember when i first went to go see the
x-men movie right the first x-fin x-men
film because when blade came out
one i wasn't really old enough to really
be able to appreciate it and two i
wasn't that knowledgeable about blade at
the time and i'm still not but with uh
i need to beef up my knowledge on blade
but with uh with the x-men of course as
anybody who's a fan of comics explained
or anything knows
the x-men is how it all started for me
actually in the animated series going
into the comics so when i went to go see
the first movie i remember getting bent
out of shape because i'm like no like
sabertooth and wolverine are supposed to
know each other they're supposed to be
like enemies and so forth and i was
hell-bent on the idea that the movie
should essentially match the comics i've
kind of grown out of that phase right at
this point it's just like film
interpretations of characters i know
from comics and their interpersonal
relationships and personal dynamics may
or may not be similar but at the end of
the day it's just as long as it's a good
movie and it's fun to watch that's
really all that matters so i don't
really expect and didn't really expect
reid to be a carbon copy in terms of
personality from the comics in the film
having said that i wasn't really
disappointed with krazynski's read i
think that he had he had authority right
he was in a position of power if
anything he felt a little detached which
is kind of how reed is reed for those
guys who aren't really familiar with
reed richards he's there but it's like
he's almost not there and in fact in the
comics that's one of the big issues
involving the interpersonal marriage
dynamics between himself and susan is
that reid is there but his mind is
always somewhere else it's always
focusing on some other problem that
needs to be solved or something like
that that was a huge part of jonathan
hickman's fantastic four when it all
kind of coalesced in the idea of reeds
solving the problem of everything and
discovering the council of reeds only to
find out that those different members of
the council of reeds were basically
alternate universe versions of
themselves who abandoned their families
like they abandoned susan and ben and
johnny franklin valeria all for like
quote unquote the greater cause reed
himself couldn't bring himself to do
that so he didn't and uh that's really
what differentiated him from pretty much
any other alter alternate reality
version of himself and so the way
krazynski presented himself as read
whether it's because of how the
character was written or because of the
direction of sam raimi in terms of how
he wanted to sort of deviate from the
screenplay a little bit insofar as like
the mannerisms of read or maybe just the
context of the situation i thought he
did great basically being a little bit
disconnected the funny thing here and
this is gonna sound a little weird and
i'm curious to see if anybody else felt
this way but the funny thing is having
seen so much of krazynski's work right
going from the office which of course is
where you and i and everybody else in
existence was first introduced to him
going into like 13 hours and like the
jack ryan series and all that kind of
stuff and especially like a quiet place
right the first film
when i was watching this it kind of
looked like krazynski was acting down
you know what i mean like looking at
krazynski and looking at the kind of
things he's done it's like he's a better
actor than the roles he was given it
looked like he was amateur hour right
like he was like he's this this like i i
don't know how to explain it but it's
like this great actor who is basically
playing a role
that doesn't require him to push his
acting chops to the limits and actually
show us what he can really do as an
actor instead it's just reading a series
of lines
you know and and that's not a slant
against krasinski if anything it's a
slant against the writing because when
it came to doctor strange too and i
guess we can do a little bit of a
spoiler review here right we're a week
out right we could add this in there
when it comes to doctor strange too was
the movie fun yes did i have a great
time watching it sure were there
problems absolutely like the death of
maria rambo right how does this girl die
getting crushed by like a giant statue
and i think the prevailing theory which
in and of itself is a problem but the
prevailing theory out there as well you
know scarlet witch probably took her
powers away that's stupid right the
purpose of the movie is to tell you why
things are happening it's not as though
they create some film where wanda just
suddenly attacks the illuminati and then
like basically the the second half of
the second act going into the third act
that's just that's where the movie picks
up but it just happens and you have no
idea what's going on and like well we'll
explain it in interviews afterwards
we'll give you context of the movie that
you saw no your job is to put context in
the movie so we don't have to ask a
whole bunch of questions for things that
are otherwise obvious right or should be
obvious the death of maria rambo
should have been pretty easily
understood people shouldn't have to
craft theories it should be anybody who
is a little uncertain and ask the
question people are just like no you
missed this part in the movie and here's
the absolute answer that we all agree to
be true because we know it's true
because we saw the film right so again
you know that's just one of the little
things that i noticed and there's a few
other things here and there that felt a
little off things that were being done
just for the sake of it like literally
the entirety of wanda's motivation came
down to a family guy meme where it's
like quagmire and it's peter and it's
brian sitting around and brian's like no
no you don't understand until you have
kids you don't understand that's
literally the entirety of wanda's
motivation in the whole film so it was a
little flimsy there but again just like
we said in the the spoiler-free review
that we did this is the equivalent of
the empire strikes back for the you know
extra dimensional multiversal magical
world in the marvel cinematic universe
it's just giving us a few you know great
little cameos characters that we'll
likely see later on and giving us
information and that's basically it it
wasn't really designed to be a
conclusion and to wrap things up so uh
but again you know kind of focusing on
read by focusing a little more on on
krasinsky and and his uh portrayal of
read i didn't really have a problem with
it you know and and that's one of the
things is i saw a lot of different
comments a lot of different posts social
media different things like that where
people were talking about you know how
anti-climactic and disappointing it was
when wanda killed the illuminati let me
tell you something man as a comic book
fan one i suspected that was gonna
happen but i didn't necessarily know i
was like maybe some of them survive and
like they they end up for whatever
reason getting sent out or maybe they
escape with america chavez and they end
up in the main marvel universe or
something like that right like you know
one of those things where it's like
we're gonna be in wanda's own backyard
the last place you would expect you know
something along those lines you know
what i mean like that kind of that kind
of a situation but then when they all
died i was like yep that sounds about
right because let me tell you something
man as a comic book fan as soon as wanda
came walking into the illuminati
headquarters i was like
curtains
drapes
it's over sun it's over everybody here
is gonna die i i figured that was gonna
be the case because one they were
building wanda up to just that level of
power and two she had basically lost her
mind right any symbols of sanity was out
the window what you guys saw in this
movie was essentially the equivalent of
avengers disassembled it's essentially
what it was you know it's not exact but
in avengers disassembled wanda was
convinced that the avengers had taken
her kids that her kids were real and the
avengers had like taken her children
from her and so she literally freaked
out and just used her magic and did a
use chaos magic and did all kinds of
stuff right avengers disassembled is the
prelude to house of m it actually it
literally sets it up if you want to
understand house of m you have to read
avengers disassembled because at the end
of that story magneto takes wanda away
and he ends up taking her to uh taking
her to the ruins of jenosha which is
where 16 million mutants were before
they were all killed by cassandra nova
but like he takes her there and that's
where house of m picks up so you kind of
have to know you have to read one to
understand the other but literally she
goes on a war path like she manifests an
entire cree armada above the avengers
mansion she uses her power to make tony
stark look drunks with stock tanks so he
can't fund the avengers anymore i mean
there's all kinds of cool stuff that
goes on there hawkeye dies which no one
cared although it was a funny moment
because he's like not like this and then
flies into the end of the cree warship
and then then like blows up and like
that's it and i was like okay
i laughed i'm not even gonna lie i
laughed a little bit i probably
shouldn't have but i did but unless like
that's basically what this movie was is
it was a modified version of avengers
disassembled on a much grander scale
wanda just rampaging through the
multiverse killing basically everybody
in her path and it was cool like i i
enjoyed that part of it i enjoyed being
able to see the character of wanda all
that grief all that anger all that pain
just manifest and let loose i loved that
right so the shortcomings of the movie
were more than made up for by just the
the great moments and how everything
just sort of went through went through
seamlessly but again you know i'm sorry
focusing back on you know kind of kind
of staying on track here focusing back
on karzinski's read didn't really have a
problem with it pretty much what i
expected from john krasinski playing
reed richards you know an actor of his
caliber i kind of expected that now
having said that even then my
perspective here is limited as is yours
because he was in the movie for a
cumulative
what like 15 minutes
maybe at most the only way to really
know if krazynski is a great reed
richards is to one let him have a hand
in writing the fantastic four movie and
then of course see him in the fantastic
four movie and the reason why i say that
is because one we know from movies like
a quiet place he can write he's a great
screenwriter um he's not the absolute
best that there ever was but he's solid
enough that he can basically craft his
own project and it can be phenomenal if
you guys never saw a quiet place you
need to go watch it it's got like a 90
plus percent on rotten tomatoes i want
to say like a 96 or a 97 it's a
phenomenal movie it's absolutely amazing
but uh you know having him have a hand
in that i think is important because
while he wouldn't have total control
over the fantastic four film he would be
able to write uh wright reed richards in
a way that would be the most conducive
to him as an actor so it would basically
be able to highlight his his strengths
and minimize his weaknesses as an actor
despite how great he may be because
that's really kind of what you saw in
doctor strange too it was the general
role of reed wretchers right like a role
for read that could have been done by
anybody and on some level sure any actor
or an actor if they're good enough can
build themselves around a particular
character but the reality here is that
actors shine their best when a character
is written almost exactly in their
likeness because then they stop acting
like a character they're portraying and
they act like themselves and that works
that's real that's one of the best ways
in which you see actors perform roles
you know again him directing it him
starring in it that's when i think you
would really be able to come to a
determination as to whether or not john
krasinski is an effective reed richards
but i'm going to say i'm going to call
it right now i think he is i think
krazynski is a great reed richards i
think that the the lackluster
performance that people say he had in
doctor strange too was more of a more
result of the screenwriting for reed
richards than it was przinski himself i
think he looked the part i think he
sounded the part i i loved it i thought
it was great and i would love to see
krasinski come back as reed richards to
me it was it was just it was like my
moment i was like yes i've been
screaming for this for so long uh and i
was so happy to see it so yeah i mean
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments right because i i feel like
having seen it in different places right
it's kind of hard to get an actual
determination but let me know down in
the comments section what you guys
thought about john krasinski playing
reed richards do you think he was great
did you think he was yeah was it
everything you hoped for because for me
it was i loved it i loved seeing him as
he he looks the part man he looks
exactly like reed and i thought it was
just it was it was great so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i'll catch you all later peace